let's take some phone calls and see
what's going on with people 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 is the number Gen brainy from
congressional dish pad cast is here with
me and will go first to the 9 5 2 area
code so listen for your area code 9 5 2
who's this you can tell us who you are
and jump right into your question hey
David I'm TK how are you doing good
sorry what was your name Oh
TK ok TK got it go ahead what's on your
mind today um I don't have a question or
anything I just want to warn you okay be
careful home vegan extremists Pat uh-huh
she's trying to take over your spot okay
he want to take over he's not a power
trip yeah be careful thank you he can
look at him right he's like over he's
trying to take over the show you mean
right TK yeah yeah I actually explained
a TK fascinating thank you I actually
explained to Jen off-camera that when we
have guest host sometimes people will
say you know ru is it possible that the
guest host will take over the David
Pakman show and some people just sort of
don't understand how businesses work
anyway yeah people are worried about
your vegan extremism though Pat I don't
see how people think that I can take
over the show right I don't hear just
one episode like I can't handle that I'm
busy enough over here producing you can
see what Pat is doing during the day
yeah